-Just a reminder.
And a lot of people
are rushing out to get gifts.
But there's one gift
in particular
that you might want to avoid.
And I know this
from personal experience.
Let me tell you about it
in song.
♪♪
It's Valentine's Day,
and you're opening gifts.
You'd settle for some candy
or a sweet little kiss.
A card for some flowers,
that's a great place to start.
But as for me, I got a giant
teddy bear holding a heart.
That's right.
♪ I got a giant teddy bear ♪
♪ On Valentine's Day ♪
-♪ Valentine's Day ♪
-♪ It's big and it's fluffy
and it's always in the way ♪
-♪ Always in the way ♪
-♪ It's holding a heart
that says "I love you" ♪
-♪ I love you ♪
-♪ But I don't know
where to put it ♪
♪ I don't know what to do ♪
♪♪
I ain't got no room
for this thing,
but I don't want to offend.
If I threw it out, my lover
might become,
well, just a friend.
It don't fit in my closet,
and I don't want to ruin it,
but I ain't dropping 40 bucks a
month for its own storage unit.
♪ I got a giant teddy bear
on Valentine's Day ♪
-♪ On Valentine's Day ♪
-♪ It's big and it's fluffy
and it's always in the way ♪
-♪ It's always in the way ♪
-♪ I took it to the curb 'cause
this thing has got to go ♪
♪ But the garbage man
saw its size ♪
♪ And said hell no ♪
♪♪
So I took it to a field,
and I just left it there.
But when I got back inside,
it was sitting in a chair.
Now, its eyes were glowing red,
and I swear that this was true.
When I looked at the heart,
it said, "I'm watching you."
♪ I got a giant teddy bear
on Valentine's Day ♪
-♪ On Valentine's Day ♪
-♪ It's big and it's creepy
it'll never go away ♪
-♪ Never go away ♪
-♪ I'm scared for my life,
I can never stop it ♪
-♪ Never stop it ♪
-♪ Next year,
I hope the one I love ♪
♪ Just gets me chocolate ♪
Happy Valentine's, everybody!
Stick around.
Be right back
with more of "The Tonight Show."
-♪ It's always in the way ♪
♪♪
♪ I love you ♪
♪ Don't know what to do ♪
♪ Valentine's Day ♪